Narrator: What makes "Scary
Stories to Tell in the Dark"
so, well, scary
are the monsters.
The disfigured Jangly Man
and the bulbous Pale Lady
look as if they've been simply lifted
from the '80s children's books
and dropped onto the big screen.
But getting those creatures
from 2D to 3D was no simple feat.
To do it, producer Guillermo del Toro
and director André Øvredal
enlisted the help of Spectral Motion.
Through a process of sculpting, painting,
and careful scrutiny
of the original images,
here's how the monsters for
"Scary Stories" came alive.
This is Mike Elizalde,
president and creative
director of Spectral Motion.
You've seen their work.
Mike Elizalde: The film that
we're known for is "Hellboy."
Since then, we've done several
other high-profile films,
including "X-Men," "Fantastic
Four," "Attack the Block."
We worked on the first
season of "Stranger Things."
Narrator: For "Scary Stories
to Tell in the Dark,"
del Toro picked Spectral Motion to bring
the book's iconic images to life.
Now, usually, when creating characters
from an existing source, like
in the case of "Hellboy,"
his team would have
hundreds of illustrations
to inform their designs.
But for "Scary Stories," in most cases,
they had only one illustration
by artist Stephen Gammell.
So, to start, Spectral enlisted
special-effects designers
Mike Hill and Norman Cabrera
to help bring the monsters to life.
Mark Viniello: He was very
vocal about, you know,
the art direction,
and we would constantly send him updates.
But what I recall is the first edict was
they have to be as true to the
source material as possible.
Like, that's bottom line.
They have to be a representation
of that original art.
So, we had the pictures
everywhere as a constant reminder
to everybody, like, this
is what we're going for.
Norman Cabrera: You have
one picture per story,
but they were just such great,
strong, iconic single images
that it was just really
important to capture that feel.
Narrator: One of the first things
they had to decide was
what type of creature
they were going to make.
Instead of making puppets, Spectral Motion
wanted each one to be a performer,
which dictated how they
would create the character.
Cabrera: We would
literally take the drawing,
the Stephen Gammell
drawing, and in Photoshop,
like, lay it over to make
sure that all the lines
are right where they should
be and that sort of thing.
Narrator: But these
characters are gonna be in 3D.
In the case of the Scarecrow design,
Norman created a digital
art version in this program,
ZBrush, to start designing the angles
not captured in the illustration.
But the most important thing
was to nail the front shot.
Once they got approval
from del Toro and Øvredal,
they finished a more detailed sculpt,
made a mold, and filled
it with foam latex.
The pieces are designed
to fit specific actors.
In some instances, the actor's
physicality directly informs
the look and feel of the
character they were playing.
The Toeless Corpse, for example,
was played by Javier Botet,
who's worked with del Toro
on "Crimson Peak" and "Mama."
Viniello: Javier Botet is
an incredible creature-suit performer.
He has very unique
physical characteristics
that we were able to,
starting with that as our foundation,
really helped in the translation
from a 2D drawing into something 3D.
Narrator: Another creature
actor, Troy James,
who played the Jangly
Man, brought a new level
of physicality that
required more attention
because of the amount
of bending and twisting
the character had to do.
Viniello: We had some new ground to break,
as far as having him come in
maybe a little more frequently
than we normally would for a creature suit
because of the unique
physicalities of the character
and how we had to work around that.
So, it's just a matter of
having the actors available
to come in repeatedly.
And we'll put him in the
suit and we'll take video.
We'll see, OK, this is
working, this isn't.
We've got to address this.
Narrator: I want to point
out that these moves
are not done with wires or CGI.
He can really move like that.
Elizalde: When we first learned about
what the Jangly Man had to do,
we started scratching our
heads and asking each other,
"Who's gonna play this character?"
And then we became aware of
an actor named Troy James,
who had done a spot on
"America's Got Talent,"
and we took a look at
his work and we thought:
"He's the guy. This guy can do anything."
Narrator: Once in costume,
the next stage was painting.
Both the suits and the performer's skin
were painted with acrylics.
This stage had its own set of challenges.
For the Pale Lady, del Toro
and Øvredal wanted it to appear
as if the creature's dress
had merged with her skin.
To do so, Mike Hill had to
create a smooth paint job
void of any garment lines on her skin.
Cabrera: It was really cool.
I know Guillermo was
particularly happy with this one,
because it was such a large and,
not abstract, but, you know,
it's one of those things
that could be widely interpreted,
like, what you're looking at.
Stephen's drawings, they
have a sketchy vibe to them,
so not every line is
realized, so to speak,
you know, in the real world.
Narrator: The Pale Lady costume
had to be put on almost
like a giant snowsuit.
Once in, to create the seamless look,
they glued up the seams
and painted over them.
Now, keep in mind, these are
black-and-white drawings.
For a character like the Toeless Corpse,
they chose a color palette
to give her a "nicotine-stained" feel,
using rotted browns
and earth-toned colors.
They also had to tackle the challenge
of giving this character's
face a skeletal look.
To do so, they added pronounced teeth
outside the actor's mouth,
a technique used for zombies
on "The Walking Dead."
They painted a majority
of the actor's body
and covered him with almost
30 individual applications
to create the finished look.
But the one thing crucial to the design
required a missing toe.
So Spectral designed a foot
that would be finished
later in post-production.
The hair for those two
were custom-made wigs
by Lynne Watson.
She's done costume hair work
for "Planet of the Apes,"
"Lone Ranger," and my personal favorite,
"Team America: World Police."
Each wig took over three weeks to make
and are both made with human hair.
When designing the Scarecrow,
Cabrera and the team asked:
What would farmers in
the world of this movie
make a scarecrow out of, and how well
would they have built it?
They decided to give the Scarecrow
a look as though it had
a 2-by-4 skeletal frame
and was completely beaten
up by the elements.
For the Jangly Man,
the character made up of
different limbs and body parts,
each segment of the creature
would therefore have
different levels of rot.
So, although several designers
all worked on this one suit,
they would each work on
various limbs separately,
focusing on a unique level of rot.
Del Toro would visit and guide the artists
on how rotted certain parts would be
and how they should look.
Once they were in the suit, painted up,
detailed, and ready to shoot,
the final step was getting the movement
of the characters right.
Along with the direction
of Øvredal and del Toro,
production hired motion coaches
to develop the performance.
The actor, director, and
even the creature designer
would all work together
to give the monster
that perfectly terrifying
presence on camera.
Cabrera: It is like a Dr.
Frankenstein kind of thing,
you know? Like, you're making a monster.
This thing has to live.
And even though it's
not living in real life,
it's living in a movie.
So, you're taking this from nothing
that didn't live before,
and now it's alive.
And that's, like, a great feeling
when you finally see it on film
and it's this living, breathing
thing that's convincing
'cause it's in the dramatic
context of a movie.
And that's the best reward there is.